we were the first to talk to Kathie Lee
Gifford this morning about her decision
to leave the Today Show and the big
question on everyone's mind the most
blessed person on earth
whoever Potawatomi T was with Kathie Lee
and Hoda as they took their show on the
road in Manhattan this is all about kog
remember have a spell my name her last
day will be April 7th but Kathie Lee
revealed the original plan was to leave
her post a year earlier I went to our
bosses and said I'm gonna do one more
year with Hoda woman and so that was the
arrangement until we had some turmoil
here laughs you know and in our midst we
found out early this morning about our
colleague Matt Lauer and our friend Noah
Optima came to me and basically said
Cathy can you just stay as et reported
Jenna Bush Hager is now the leading
contender to replace Kathie Lee you know
what you get you deserve this
whomever ultimately gets the gig they
will have a mighty task to duplicate
their TV chemistry Kathie Lee told me
what it's like having that magic twice
Regis and Hoda how great was it working
with those oh you know what I mean how
many people get lightning in a bottle
two times in their life when I retired
from television because of you know I
thought I'd done the best 15 years of
television I could do with the amazing
Regis and then to come back after eight
years and and and be with Hoda who you
know was Dateline Hoda back then yeah
she was oh she's happy our Hoda Kathie
Lee is the best and you know what a
little bit later we're gonna dive into
the et archives we have spent so much
time with Kathie Lee her late husband
Frank and their kids we're gonna
flashback to when we first met Kathie
Lee Johnson yes and she had just gotten
engaged to Frank
ET archives never disappointed they're
never ever there so fantastic
you
[Music]